i love charlotte man i've been here for
two days a stroll around your downtown i
do have a bone to pick with you
charlotte i got i gotta bring this up i
have a bone to pick with you
i can't believe
the lack of respect for mugsy bugs in
this town are you [ __ ] me
i thought i figured he was a big deal
billboards how do you have a statue of
mutsy boats
after all he's five three dude
he played 14 seasons in the nba
he averaged a double double one year for
the charlotte hornets you can't put up a
statue
philadelphia has a statue of rocky
balboa
it's gonna be real
once he's five three
in miami they have a statue of daddy
yankee
[ __ ]
he was a legend
he's my favorite player as a kid
because we're the same size my favorite
player
i figured you guys would just toast the
town to him i figured you'd everything
logistically i'm walking apart it's like
lego land for monty guys i'm walking
around with [ __ ] stools this time
it's earned it charlotte
5'3 in the 90s
in the end being the 90s what is real
basketball [ __ ] 14 years
charlotte i don't have a [ __ ] statue
just think about logistically the
average player that nba in the 90s was
six eight you know how many dicks were
in that man's face
he played with alonzo morning
alonzo seven foot tall
that good free throw [ __ ] mo deep
larry johnson hey way to go
i'm in the locker room after games
dodging dicks like this jumanji in that
[ __ ] place
[ __ ] that man's baby can't put up a
statue
i was like well maybe he wasn't that
good so i looked up his highlights today
on youtube in 1994. this is a video of
him for whatever reason he's [ __ ]
guarding charles barkley one on one five
three [ __ ] like this charles barkley
dick
[ __ ] steals the ball
lays out
legend charlotte [ __ ] legend
i'm just saying show them a little
respect